have a stormwater utility it's not for
any other thing you want to do so it's
in the context of that
that if you're going to say
okay we're going to have this grant
program or
we're going to you know regulate you
know this also if you have stormwater
utility also regulates runoff of
pavement and how the nitrogen coming off
a parking lot is is going to be dealt
with
um
so
that's
i you know but if you think that that
needs to be clarified or that's
problematic then
you can do amendments too over here
right here
thank you
representative smith
sure um yeah thank you senator for
taking my question um i just want to
confirm that um because of where this is
in the statute this only applies to
public water systems or public
wastewater systems
not um individual
septic systems
of private uh homeowners uh thanks for
your question um
that actually is it wasn't what it does
do
see stormwater utilities are not about
your
public water waste water treatment
storm water utilities are about all the
other sources of nitrogen whether it's
runoff from parking lots
um or or otherwise as i said that's
about you know about 76 percent of the
nitrogen is coming from sources
otherwise other than
the um
waste treatment plants
and that's why
it's a that's why you know communities
around the great bay and everybody else
under ms4
has to get at that so the definition
here
on 485 a2
this is your septic
so that's why i'm describing that you
know a community who has a waste
stormwater utility now i'll be able to
say okay
um you know we're we're going to include
septic in this and it might mean that
you know maybe there's a 10 15 fee
on it or if you agree to have your your
your system inspected you don't pay the
fee and you are eligible for grant
however they want to set it up
but that's the point here is to
incorporate
those other sources of nitrogen
so that it's not
you know they're just trying to not very
articulated in a particular way saying
the problem under ms4 is they go after
the wastewater treatment plants you can
get it up to the limits of science
and you're still going to have nitrogen
go in the water so epa's going to come
back so throw another 50 million dollars
at it right and that's it's crazy making
um so that's why
the agreements was struck for the all
the great bay region estuaries to say
total nitrogen permit
will find ways to go after that other
nitrogen and if you see the reduction
sit you know community wide
water system wide
then you're not going to come back with
a hammer so that's that's that's why
this
the point of the bill is to say that if
you set up a stormwater utility
you can include
septic now community might decide we're
going to set this far more community
utility but we're not going to accept it
we just want to get out the parking lots
or the runoff that's going into our
storm storm drain system
well thank you
uh yeah i could ask for a follow-up okay
yeah thank you so this in this way
municipalities where their their lake is
getting inundated with cyanobacteria
blooms
um then they could use this if they had
the approval if they followed the rules
of the of the statute of the that would
come into place
so that sounds good thank you thanks
representatives yes yeah
thank you representative creighton
thank you mr chairman senator thank you
for your testimony i
i understand what you're trying to do
here
my question is so what if we don't pass
this
they can't i mean if it's enabling then
they could do it anyway
is there a reason that they can't do it
today
yeah
thanks for your question i believe
that's the case
if you're gonna a stormwater utility is
this
you know was in statute we enabled
municipalities to set those up and to
set fees related to them
and without the explicit inclusion here
i don't believe that is the case
i don't know if you have a letter from
commissioner scott
in support of this before you
and i think you're going to hear from
the communities as well that we do need
if you know we do need to pass this to
let them to to fully enable that okay
thank you thanks for your question
any other question
yes
i was in the uh
we all received it
uh it was
email
he was emailed to us
but there is someone from des i think is
going to be speaking as well
hopefully hopefully you have copies of
it
i have a copy of the of his letter if
you like her but
if
you better
we'll work here we'll get we'll get it
looks like
one might be coming up
but uh yeah
okay yeah just just yeah they can just
don't
is
yes
we do we definitely now have a copy i i
now have two
all right uh any other questions by
members of the committee i might before
i ask mine
uh
thank you mr chair and thank you senator
for taking my question i was wondering
in um discussing this
bill
was there any concerns about
putting fertilizer down
and and that
being an issue is that was that
addressed in any way
um thanks for your question you know i
know fertilizer has been discussed in
the past and um you know as i said being
being
i call myself a saltwater senator
because
all of us around the great bay the four
of us and you know we've been talking
about a lot of these issues for many
years and i think there's been some
fertilizer uh legislation over the years
um and dog waste may i say i hear a lot
from the folks who are doing
aquaculture operations uh in the great
bay that that's a concern for them
so yes there are other sources of
nitrogen um in my research on this uh
and i particularly was reading um from
florida and from the um
uh chesapeake bay region they say yeah
yeah fertilizer but the percentage of
nitrogen that's coming from fertilizer
is far far less
than this
so
and this makes more practical sense in a
way than trying to get at and you know
the fertilizer regulation you know
you're dealing with these national
corporations
who are formulating this they and
they've changed their formulation some
huh um to make it more long-lasting in
the breakdown of the nitrogen and and
that but um you know i i i think that
opens up
such a can of worms that this this seems
practical
representative harp for a question thank
you senator for taking my question a
follow-up to
representative smith if this bill
would affect private septic systems the
town could implement in the enabling
legislation a fee
on all private systems whether they're
contaminating setting off nitrogen or
anything just like an assessment for
everybody in town could they do that
well thanks for your question and
you know i uh
i i tend to trust our towns and um
to think that
you know we have legislative bodies and
if ideas come forward
um they have to get people to vote for
it
um my feeling is from seeing the way
these have been done
in other municipalities that they tend
to have very strong support
because people are interested in
ensuring that the environment which is
one of the reasons they probably moved
into that town in the first place
um
stays the way it is and and and
flourishes
um
i i understand and i share with you the
kind of anxieties over taxation and fees
you know i i mean i'm i'm new hampshire
too
and i think that there's no intent from
the communities i've heard from that the
point here is to encourage folks and to
provide
funding for improvement
of septic systems so that nitrogen
overall is controlled
and i think it is fair enough
to look at contributors to nitrogen i
mean that's why you know planning
departments now if somebody's going to
bring in
a supermarket and they're going to have
a
parking lot what do they do they require
the planning department require some
water garden or you know how you're
going to deal with the runoff there so
it's not just you know going into our
our lakes and streams so in a way it's
it's kind of a user
it's kind of a user orientation that if
you're
one of the if you're contributing the
nitrogen that is creating for us a
problem under ms4 then you can
participate
in the solution that's one of the
reasons i pointed to the program down
you know the bay restoration which is
all you know the states around
chesapeake bay
where they said they identify in that
process those things that are in the
critical area so that they would know
that the groundwater there yeah that's
going to go into the bay
if you're not in that critical area and
i think for them it's like within a
thousand feet or something like that i
don't know i mean it depends on the
ecology and the groundwater flows and so
on
then you're not covered by it so i'm i'm
hoping that that's the kind of
reasonable approach that our
municipalities would take
one follow-up
i'm used to dealing with massachusetts
and title v
with this enabling legislation my
concern is a municipality as kind as
they might want to be
they could probably implement or my
question is could they implement a local
ordinance that says any sale of any
property needs to have a the system
examined and if you fail you need to
upgrade it and they don't have to grant
them a grant to do it could they do that
under this legislation well thanks for
your question and i you know i'm i think
we're going to have ted dears up with us
but i and i'm i make and the realtors
you know but i think it's the case that
when there is a sale of a property now
you that's the that's the time at which
their inspection takes place
no
not statutorily
there is a bill that we are looking we
uh is on
that we are you know have retained
well
thanks for the question
here's where we're at okay
epa ms4
is coming at us right and um i feel that
our having something in our toolbox so
that we can locally decide out
what we're going to do
right i mean once federal regulation
comes down there's not a lot of fine
grade about that it's it it's a hammer
ton of bricks what you want to call it
and i
and i mean we've been through that the
great around the great bay and i think
we're going to see more of it under ms4
and um
you know this to me seems like a
practical solution though look i share
your concerns okay i
i do i i
you know i my private property is
private property and
being able to sell it and you know the
real estate market
uh
people like transparency clarity and not
anxiety about it so
i get it
anyway anyone else before i
take my question and send out my
questions first of all
what is there any urgency on this uh
relative to the federal government and
you know
i know they threaten all the time
yeah thanks for coming there's extreme
urgency
around the great bay area
and i think we're going to see extreme
urgency in other ms4 communities a
consent agreement was signed by those
communities around the great bay
after
years of
negotiation and then up right walking
right up to the line
of threatened legal action by the epa
which in which the consequences and the
hundreds of millions of dollars that
would have had been expense
would have been extreme impact on the
taxpayers and businesses who might have
just moved out of the area rather than
deal with the increase in water
treatment fees so i would say and i
think you'll hear from
from dover and elsewhere i mean that's
why they're starting to make the move
now towards stormwater utilities is
because they've been given this
opportunity
to deal with nitrogen
on a community-based way and find our
own solutions
and we have we are on a deadline
to do that
uh another another question um
you know
storm water utility storm water is
surface water
uh
septic systems is a subsurface water is
the
does the
drain do the drains uh surface water
drainage systems do they cat do they
capture anything
of the uh
leachate that might be uh
coming from
yeah thanks for the question and of
course you're right um you know storm
water uh runs off of of uh parking lots
it also gets into storm drains and
leaf litter gets in there and you know
there's a lot of programs now to clean
those out but groundwater also gets into
our lakes and rivers and into the great
bay
and that's that that that's that's the
point of this is that it all nitrogen
ends up going somewhere and that's
what is causing the impairment of the
waters and why
the epa says you've got to deal with the
it's the nitrogen however it gets there
it's the nitrogen right but i i bet i
realize it's the
question that
but treating the drainage
what's in the what's in what's in the
street drains
how much nitrogen is in there
as opposed to what
gets into the water table or what just
simply
uh goes subsurface to the to the to the
uh
to the river system
uh in other words are you treating a
whole lot of water that doesn't have any
nitrogen in it to begin with
maybe that's a question for the des
person yeah do ask that but i would just
say i mean again i know my community
and that one of the things
there's a lot of creative people working
for our communities on storm water and
on nitrogen
and uh there is a
a storm drain
um program in dover where you know to
clean them out and to put in new kinds
of drains that make sure that the leaf
litter and other other sources of dog
waste you name it all those other
sources of nitrogen don't get into the
um
into the system so it comes from it
comes from a lot of different sources it
can depend on the community
um and in terms of what percentages come
from each but uh that's what a
stormwater utility lets you do is it
lets you figure out for your community
where it's coming from and how can you
help abate it
uh just one
one additional maybe it's a comment
maybe something i should talk to the des
person about
but
i've always uh you know as long as i've
been here and and even in previous lives
you you never put storm water or surface
water into the septic system because you
hurt the septic system
and is that a
still
the the interior knowledge is that still
the general
the the general rule of thumb because
you can give
i would hate to see us
now
getting into another problem where your
the septic or your sewage systems start
failing because of too much water
entering them
well thank you mr chairman i don't i
don't think that's what this is about um
i think it's just saying that you know
the nitrogen is coming out of septic
systems you can you can look at in your
storm water utility it's not meaning
that the storm water is going to be put
into the septic systems or
or vice versa it's just it's just saying
you've got
you've got all these sources of nitrogen
and how can you figure out how to reduce
reduce the nitrogen in them
okay
thank you
uh anything more from the uh
thank you thank you very much
any questions come up afterwards you
know where to find me
i like your notebook
yeah is that only on one bill
i want to call
mr wood from
new hampshire d.e.s or
i couldn't read the person that tracy
would
okay
thank you chairman and members of the
rrnd committee my name is tracy wood i'm
the administrator of the wastewater
engineering bureau
and thank you for allowing me to testify
on sb 257
and if you don't mind i would like to
also call up ted dears from new
hampshire d s who's the administrator of
the watershed bureau
we're going to tag team this one it
actually
covers both of our bureaus to a certain
extent so and you'll probably
submit a car or a big card after you're
finished no no no finish finish off all
right
so well i'll start um on our last letter
of testimony that you have received i
would just like to say on the first page
you'll notice that the bill says the
language there is as proposed we did not
amend the language on that first page
for the amended language
that you have in front of you today but
i will say that despite that ds is in
favor of the amended language as it is
currently stands
so i tried to listen senator waters did
an amazing job giving you the background
and answering all the questions i'm
going to try to to hit on our highlights
excuse me could you move the mic over so
you can speak
sure
so just as senator waters said you know
this is enabling legislation
this gives the municipalities the
opportunity to enact
this legislation it does not require
them to do so
so that is a very important piece
this legislation
is
coming out of communities that are here
today
that are under regulatory scrutiny
you've heard ms4 you've heard great bait
total nitrogen general permit
um
and these communities um that are
subject to the these
these regulatory requirements as we all
know
um federal regulations never get less
stringent
they only get more stringent and they
get broader over time so one of the
things that the amended language did
which
as senator waters stated took out
subject to federal storm water
regulations
was a good thing because this will in
the future allow
coverage as epa expands its areas of
coverage for for the ms4 and or just
storm water regulations in general
there was a statement about all plans or
proposals
um we feel that this is very important
this p this piece here was added um all
plans are proposals submitted by a
stormwater utility to the legislative
body of municipality for approval
shall include at least one estimate of
the cost of the plan prepared by a
professional entity engaged in storm
water mitigation or sewage treatment and
disposal
and why this is important if you're
going to create a utility
you have to know how you're going to
create it right you have to know the
costs what are you what are you trying
to
to treat or to to do what are you trying
to accomplish what are your goals
and then what are the costs to
accomplish those goals so your goals are
going to come out of your federal
requirements and so you need to have
that clearly established before you go
in front of the community and say
you can't just go in there and say we
want to create a stormwater utility you
have to have that plan or proposal to do
that
and i would just like to say there's
never a better time to to to create that
because with all the srf dollars that
are out there
under the clean water srf program
such a plan would be
um eligible for our current hundred
thousand dollars planning grants
so that that that plan or proposal could
be at no cost to the the community if
they came into our program
um someone had mentioned um
you know does this does this do
communities already have the authority
to create such utility
and what we've been hearing from the
different communities it's just fuzzy it
seems like some feel that they could
have the authority and others feel that
they couldn't so what this bill would do
would would be to solidify that for
everybody
and then there was a lot of discussions
about a fee to be able to be charged to
all private septic systems
basically
yes they could
but that would have to be in that
planner proposal right to
and that would be putting forth uh in
front of the townspeople to be able to
create that utility so you just can't
randomly start charging people's fees
but i would also like to say that you
know
proper septic tank maintenance requires
them to be pumped on a regular basis and
we recommend every three to five years
so
and that has to go somewhere and that
has to go to a municipal wastewater
treatment facility
right now the septic fees i don't know
how many people have private septic
systems are on a community municipal
system i've been on both so i've seen
both sides
but it's a minimal fee to pump your tank
and take it to a wastewater treatment
facility for treatment
it's only a couple hundred dollars and
you only have to do it every three to
five years
now that i am on a municipal system i
think i pay over eight hundred dollars a
year for my sewage fee only
so it's it's quite a different cost
differential
and why i'm bringing that up because at
any time the wastewater treatment
facilities could decide to increase that
fee
but they haven't
and there's pros and cons to that
so
if they increase their fee for septage
pumping
uh in delivery to the treatment plant
would that now
would people think about it would they
delay their treat pumping would they
delay that that maintenance that's so
vital to the proper operation of that
septic system
and i think they would you know if it if
you go from 300 to a thousand dollars to
pump your tank a lot of people are going
to forgo that or they're going to put it
off because it's an increase in cost so
that's a very important piece they
already have that ability to increase
that cost but if they did how many
people would delay pumping and then what
environmental issues would come out of
that how many people would have failed
systems because of that
also
you know
because septage has to go to municipal
wastewater treatment facilities everyone
bears that responsibility for those
costs
so typically for wastewater treatment
facilities
you have your users and most
municipalities are set up to just charge
the the people that are directly
utilizing the wastewater treatment
facility they have a direct pipe to it
so
they're not including the private
systems so that's why you there's that
disparity that huge disparity in what i
pay as a municipal user versus what i
paid when i had a private septic system
so how do we account for that disparity
but back to the main points is that
this is enabling legislation this gives
the municipalities the ability to create
a utility if they need to
the costs are the cost the federal
regulations have requirements and the
municipalities have to abide by those
requirements so this
enables them to be able to manage those
costs in a way that works for their
community
and every community may have slightly
you know different circumstances
and so
that plan or proposal that they would
create to put in front of their
townspeople is very important so that
the transparency and the the townspeople
would know exactly what they're doing
what they're creating
and i think that's all i can read from
my scribble so
if anyone has any questions
mr dears do you have uh anything you
want to
add
um i'll just maybe answer a couple of
the questions that came up in the
previous uh testimony um so there was a
question from i believe from the chair
uh about what's the percentages of
different sources of nitrogen into the
estuary and it's interesting um
it's about uh if you take out the the
point sources which are those wastewater
treatment plants which are about 30
percent
so you have 70 percent left
and if you cut that then into chunks
uh
uh septic systems are about 40
so it is the largest chunk of the rest
of the of the the nitrogen sources
storm water
which is made up of lots of other things
storm water is made up of both
fertilizers somebody asked the question
about fertilizers fertilizers end up in
storm water
as well as atmospheric deposition so we
are down as you all i'm sure are well
aware
new hampshire is the tailpipe of the
nation when it comes to air quality and
so all of the noxas and soxes which are
not a dr seuss book
but are contaminants in our air
that those end up in our air and they
actually fall to the ground they're
scavenged by snow or they fall as as
precipitate
so those end up on the surfaces and
those get washed off in storm water all
of that together is somewhere around 30
of that you know that that non-point
source load the loads that come from
lots of different sources so certainly
lawns uh in in the great bay watershed
there's about 43 000 acres of lawns it
is by far this largest component of
agriculture if you want to call it that
and so that's a significant component as
well as things like animal um you know
waste
that is from domestic animals
and
uh
as well as fertilizers that go on
agricultural crops but those are very
small components so
yes the the answer the fact of the
matter is is that humans uh discharge uh
on the order i think the senator said
something like 40 pounds a year uh per
perceptic system was an estimate down in
maryland we've estimated that each
human's about seven pounds a year we
emit uh in terms of our nitrogen
so i think that answered that question
um
trying to recall
the
other questions that came up
um
but i think some of this some of what i
think will be helpful to you is to kind
of hear how one of these things would
work in the context of a real discussion
going on in a real community
and so there are some folks that are
sitting behind us who are those doers on
the ground
who who i think can speak to some of the
practical matters of how this would
actually work
right so so i i guess this is
bears also just a sort of a science
piece of this is that
septic systems are pretty good at
getting phosphorus out of the
of wastewater because phosphorus absorbs
onto other things it sticks to other
things so when it gets stuck pumped out
you're pumping out a lot of that
phosphorus and when it goes into your
leach field most of that phosphorus gets
soaked up or it gets attached
into yourself into your leach field
nitrogen is a very different matter
nitrogen becomes dissolved and what a
septic system does really well is take
things that are dissolved and put them
into the groundwater
that is what's meant to do
in some ways you can think of a septic
system as the perfect dissolved nitrogen
discharge system into groundwater it
does it extremely effectively and it
very little treatment because it's
anaerobic within the the soils in your
septic system so you get very little
treatment of nitrogen as it goes through
the system this is why
as we start to talk about this issue it
becomes kind it becomes an interesting
one and one in which why it becomes
expensive and one it one way
one reason why it might make sense to
have a stormwater utility that includes
a wastewater utility that includes
septic systems is because you could
include some of those more expensive
systems so that the cost would not be
borne by the the homeowner necessarily
it could be spread out you could get
grants you could go to tracy's program
which by the way has lots and lots and
lots of money right now for srf grants
for infrastructure and we'll have more
over the next five years
so so there's an opportunity here to be
able to attack some of these very
expensive and very difficult issues in
this manner that would allow for this to
happen in a way that would not affect
the homeowner nearly to the extent that
it otherwise might if you didn't have
this kind of mechanism available to a
community
i think i can stop there and we can see
what questions you have
thank you very much as always for your
testimony um
senator grassley mentioned the
fines
potential fine from the epa
uh are those imminent and and what's the
magnitude of that and and would this
legislation help us
avoid those fines
so
the the way that permits work is you
have to kind of meet your permit
um i don't think that there are fines
imminent
the problem is the long-term
effectiveness of how you're going to
meet the nitrogen reductions within your
permit
and i think that there are these people
here behind us that can probably speak
to that better
in that
they're looking ahead five years
so if you start looking ahead five years
you can get to certain reductions fairly
easily as you get further down the road
those become harder and harder so the
real question is is what happens five
years from now in the next permit and
how are you prepared for that and how
are you addressing the kinds of sources
you know that you can get to for the
lowest dollar possible you want to hit
the lowest the lowest cost the lowest
marginal cost per unit of nitrogen
i took economics a lot in college so
it's that that is that is the whole idea
here and that's why this legislation is
out there is to be allowed the
flexibility to be able to attack that
lowest cost piece of nitrogen or
phosphorus whatever it is that you're
you're trying to do in your particular
community
on the enforcement piece
the goal of epa is not to issue fines
the goal is to have communities do the
work that they need to do and accomplish
that so they would only
save the fines for those communities
that aren't working or making progress
towards the goals of the permits because
it's
it's futile to spend money on fines they
want communities to spend the moneys on
accomplishing the goals and improving
the water quality in great bay and other
areas in our state
okay thank you
anyone else
seeing no
uh one you very much for your testimony
i just a couple quick questions
um could you tell me the name of the
grants and
uh just for point of clarification
so
a municipality
could mitigate nitrogen
in their
you know treatment plants coming to
their treatment plants
if
could they do this theoretically test
the sewage that's coming in for nitrogen
and then say
you know you're you've got
you know so many parts per million so
we're going to charge you an extra fee
um
and also like that would be a way of
educating the public to
you know here here are some ways that
you can mitigate your nitrogen
um
is by you know not fertilizing your lawn
for instance as as often um
but
so that would be would that be one way
to do it that's a question
and i guess i should just stop there
because
there's too many questions
would that be one feasible way i guess
and then the name of the grants
okay so um the grants or uh the loans
that we give with subsidy 100 subsidy is
for the clean water state revolving fund
and we're offering um a hundred thousand
dollar planning grants
and we're actually going to be
soliciting for projects our annual
process is about to get underway so by
friday we should have our solicitation
out and then we have communities can
submit pre-applications
and they're due by june 1st
and then
on the septic piece this the septic
systems as ted stated
are not designed to treat for nitrogen
so
they're go
when you pump your tank they know
they're bringing the nitrogen to the
treatment plant so you're saying charge
a fee based on the amount of nitrogen in
that
um well do they test um could would it
be feasible i guess to test every
um
input you know every uh deposit to the
the sewage system and then that way they
could educate the
uh to maybe prevent the nitrogen in the
future
i don't know
i i think the way that could be
accomplished it would not
be feasible to test every
theft itch load pumped um pollers you
know how they can they can pump several
systems and then they're gonna take that
combined load go to the treatment plant
um
but they could do a quick test i'm
thinking out loud here i'm sorry they
could do a quick test i think the way to
accomplish that would be to
you know just having a general knowledge
of what
type amount of nitrogen comes out of
septic systems
there are other constituents in our
septic tanks beyond nitrogen um we have
a lot of copper you know we have copper
in our in our houses and there's copper
and our septage and amongst other things
so nitrogen's actually not the only
issue but
and ted go ahead yes yeah i think what
you're raising is exactly the point of
why someone would create a utility
okay so this is this is exactly how a
storm water utility works and i think
gretchen young from dover is going to
talk about that a little bit
is that
you would have a certain amount of of
property that has a certain about
ability to generate
pollution
whether it be fertilizers or whether it
be your your amount of imperviousness or
the other things going on on your
property so let's say that you're
connected into the stormwater system
this is stormwater side not septic side
septic site is different but the
stormwater side would do exactly what
you're suggesting is that there's a
metric
of how much pollution you're creating
from your particular property and then
the utility is then bases its fee on
that metric
and how you get that metric how you get
that fee to go down
is by changing your behavior on that
particular piece of property so that
creates the financial incentive for
people to reduce their pollution which
is why a storm water utility works to
actually reduce storm water
pollutants over time it also generates
the dollars necessary to do centralized
treatment of some of that kind of stuff
whether it be you know storm drains or
improvements or you know kind of
infiltration basins green infrastructure
generally which is also fundable through
our srf program i never forget um so so
anyway that's kind of the subject
system's a little harder
we
we don't have a lot of ways for us to
change that behavior of ourselves um
with exception those of you who remember
uh the folks talking over in over in
burlington um talking about urine
diversion i don't know if you remember
that conversation i think that actually
came up in this body a couple of times
in which if you actually divert urine
which has primary which has most of the
nitrogen is actually in urine and not in
feces
sorry just have to put it out there um
is that by collecting that using it for
fertilizer you actually kill two birds
with one stone but that's a little more
radical than i think most humans are
ready for
at this particular juncture
anyone else
questions
thank you very much
chris norwood in opposition to the bill
thank you mr chair members of the
committee
my name is chris norwood i am the 2022
public policy
chair of the new hampshire association
of realtors
and on behalf of our members were coming
today
as the chair mentioned to oppose this
bill
i do want to thank senator waters for
bringing this bill up i understand that
the ms4 and nitrogen in general is a
complicated issue i think where our
concerns lie
is uh the very
very portion of the bill that creates a
a public utility that is very broad and
open-ended relative to what the
municipalities can and cannot do
so if passed sb 257 would for the first
time make privately owned septic systems
become part of a public utility
that is a significant step for new
hampshire and could have implications
further down the road
by making private septics part of a
public utility this legislation would
potentially allow municipalities to
mandate upgrades
new systems or property owners and fees
and we don't have any guard rails in
this
legislation that talks about what those
fees and those
inspections and those timelines might
look for
so for example on the fee side of the
house the current statute rsa 149 i 6
hyphen d
does have a fee for calculating excuse
me has a formula for calculating fees
that formula is relative to impervious
surface on a subject properties lot
which makes sense in the context of
stormwater runoff but not in the context
of a private septic system
so what would be the fees imposed we
don't know and i think as senator waters
raised
that is our concern and again we
understand and respect the reasons for
the legislation but it's are those
unknowns that are concerning us for our
uh for our uh private property owners
um
one bullet point according to our
research and curious what the des would
say nearly one half
of new hampshire residential properties
are serviced by septic systems and
therein lies one of our concerns
in 2019
new hampshire association of realtors
participated in the shoreland septic
system study commission established by
house bill 475.
the ideas of fees on private septic
systems were not part of that
recommendation of the commission and nor
do we think fees were ever discussed at
that time
and our concern goes to these fees and
also what the mandates from the
individual municipalities may be
not all septic systems are potential
threats to increasing nitrogen loads
the currently as the des suggested
recommends pumping every three to five
years
a new properly well maintained is not
the same as a failed system and this
bill does not distinguish between the
two and leaves that decision entirely in
the hands of the municipality
nhar would hope that the state would
look at the significant dollars
available through the federal
infrastructure bill before looking to
add new costs and new fees to private
property owners
this legislation which requires a great
deal
more discussion in the new hampshire
association of realtors are prepared to
be part of those discussions but we ask
you not to pass sb 257 and i thank you
very much for your time
questions
yes thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um when uh the
sponsor of the bill testified he said
that when the bill first as it was
introduced only covered the great bay
area pretty much
um the town's affected by the msr
permitting process through epa
and so would you have less would the
realtors have less
problem if the bill was amended back to
its original state so it only covered
those municipalities affected by the
federal mandate
thank you representative for the
question
i think that the
the opening of a public utility
um at a municipal level without
definition of
what the municipality's
power is
their amount of the fees and what the
either the testing
or the requirements and penalties that
they could impose on a private property
owner those are our concerns uh the
geographic
the number of municipalities
i i believe that would be part of it
representative smith but it's really the
the unknown part that is created by this
enabling legislation that is the broader
concern
thank you
any other questions
did you submit any kind of
write-up of your
testimony
no representative i did not but happy to
send something to you
thank you mr chair
we're all getting older
the alternative is what you
don't want
um
let's see i have two people from dover
are you doing this they're this together
are you doing it separately
uh i can
but ever
i'll give your choices because
sometimes it's best to you play off one
another
uh this uh dennis uh
dennis
shanahan and gretchen young
again you both represent
mr
shanahan represents the dover city
council
and
ms young
city of dover administer and also so i
guess the municipal alliance for
adaptive management yes exactly right
thank you very much and the floor is
yours however you wish to break it up
and you can don't worry we'll wing it
but i'll start with some preliminary
yeah
discussion thank you for having us
chairman vice chair committee members uh
i'm dennis shanahan uh from the city
council and the deputy mayor of the the
city of dover uh more pertinent to this
discussion i was also the chair of the
the citizen committee that recently
adopted a proposal and provided it to
the city council to establish a
stormwater utility uh dover i think is
probably a little bit ahead of most of
the other cities in the state although i
think your host city concord is is
pretty close and portsmouth i know is is
working on that so this was a diverse
committee uh very well selected
individuals from all from all areas from
business owners uh property owners
engineers uh technical folks the dover
city council accepted the committee's
report and our process is designed to to
make it thoughtful
well planned out
at this point with the acceptance of the
report we have tasked our city manager
uh to begin
fine-tuning the details that need to
come along a lot of the details have
discussed been discussed a little bit
this morning uh our expectation is by
the end of next year there'll be a
proposal
for the affirmation of an ordinance that
will establish the utility and then
begin uh utility operations uh the first
of uh fiscal year 25 july 1st 2024. uh
so we are we're being careful cautious
we're taking our time uh and watching
things like this that may have an effect
on it
so as you've heard there
among 12 other communities in the
watershed we recently received our great
bay nitrogen uh general total nitrogen
general permit
as gretchen will speak to is that the
part three of this permit establishes
the development of adapted management
framework to continue to iterately
improve the water quality in great bay
this uh this came after as you heard
from senator waters after an extended
period of negotiations discussions uh
with the uscpa des conservation law
foundation uh and
we felt that we really got to uh the
place everyone needed to be with the the
development of this adapted management
framework
so
the alliance understands that the
efforts to restrict contaminants can't
be exclusive to the wastewater treatment
plant you've heard the numbers kicked
around about uh the split between point
sources non-point sources and then
within the non-point sources the split
with septic and and other sources that's
well understood uh in the permit and in
fact if you look at
the several pages of uh actions for for
municipalities to look at there are lots
of efforts to take on including things
like nitrogen for high nitrogen
fertilizer reduction if at all possible
the use of organic treatments
one of my other uh
tasks that i did when i was uh early in
the council is that i had a resolution
pass that limited fertilizer use in the
city of dover on publicly owned lands to
just those that contain low nitrogen
organic type fertilizers so we are
trying to take this on
at a number of different fla in
different fronts
so
the
the committee really had two
foundational principles that they were
working on in determining whether or not
to go ahead with the utility because the
purpose of this committee was to choose
a funding alternative do you do you fund
it with the general fund basically
property taxes do you fund it with
individualized type district locations
do you find it with a utility do you
fund it with public private partnerships
and ultimately we really came down this
to really two choices there's a utility
there's using property taxes out of the
general fund because you're always going
to rely on public property uh
public-private partnerships to to
accomplish things you've got to work
with developers to make to make it come
out right and you're always going to
work to get as many of the the grants uh
that you can and listening to def
testimony was going to start writing
some stuff because this sounds like this
now we have we recognize the state's
been very supportive of this and look
forward to working with them so the two
foundational
aspects were one
build in equitable equitability in the
the charges associated with dealing with
storm water
costs
right now
the amount that you pay towards
storm water mitigation water
improvements is based on the value of
your property
so that the amount you pay towards storm
water could increase if you put a new
floor in your kitchen if you add a
bathroom to your upstairs that doesn't
seem to be well tuned it really should
be based on your contribution to the
effort uh
the need for the effort to to reduce
stormwater contaminants and to better
manage it which is done by a
the selection of the
equivalent residential unit for
impermeability on your property
so in dover the average single family
house has about a 3 400 square foot area
of impermeable surface you drive away
your roof maybe your patio
and this is all captured by satellite
images put into a gis system and has
been
reasonably well documented
and from that to support a three and a
half million dollar a year expected cost
for storm water management that comes
down to about 128 dollars per single
family residence
obviously if you're a larger business
particularly a business with a large
parking lot your share is going to be
bigger because you're contributing more
contaminants into the system so the
committee's determination was about
equity
and they found a utility to be more
equitable
but as importantly and it really was a
50 50 split that the other piece is to
improve water quality period
if we can't improve water quality with
the utility or any of our efforts
then we're wasting time we're wasting
money it really has to be the drive
behind the city with the citizens behind
us to improve the quality of the water
that ultimately ends up uh in the great
bay estuary
on its way to the great bay it also goes
through the eisenglass the coachico the
bellamy where we swim we fish we boat so
water quality improving the rivers it is
also just as important
so looking at septic systems it really
is
pretty obvious that you need to include
that as part of this effort
and more importantly and has been talked
about this morning
the words option flexibility and
enablement are part of it because that's
how this state works you you enable a
city like dover to be able to build that
into its systems so stepping back into
my role as deputy mayor and thinking
about what kind of things can we do
dover
is is not likely at all
to mandate inspections
we're not likely to get involved in the
transaction of a piece of property as
part of a stormwater initiative
what are we likely to do
and this is similar to how we're going
to build the rest of our stormwater
utility
we're going to set a fee tell the
individual property owner this is the
amount that you owe
and then that property owner can say
well can you take a look at this
i have two rain gardens i have an
underwater gravel watershed
i have this other
base best management practice built into
my property
and our system is going to have the
required credit system and you can back
off from that fee
one of those credits could very well be
hey i can show i've been pumping my
system
and i'll get a credit for that maybe i
can show that while they're pumping it
this qualified inspector has taken a
look and said yep yours is in good shape
that could result in a credit
and also when there is a failure when
there is a problem possibly the utility
could build reserve funds and help that
homeowner out
we're going through a problem
in a corner of our city right now where
a pretty good sized neighborhood with a
common uh sewer system had a complete
failure and i i believe it had to do
with the way that was installed the
contractor put it in poorly but the city
responded and said well the best way to
deal with this
is to get septic out to that
out to that neighborhood it's going to
reduce the contaminants that were coming
out these poor folks had to have their
tanks pumped every third day just to try
and get by and be able to wash their
clothes and use their toilets so the
city responded spent the money and were
able to respond and get them on a septic
system
a few years from now with the utility
going going forward
there may be reserve funds that can help
out with that instead of tapping into
the general fund and using property tax
levies for that um so i think that's
where the equity comes in so that that's
dover's perspective uh
speaking as you know again as the deputy
mayor there are things that
we would do we know we wanted it was in
our proposal that we know we want to
recommend a credit system we know that
it's required we know there'd be
litigation without it
we're now down to the details well can
you credit your way to zero or do you
need a margin because you've got to
support citywide efforts
and what's the value of each one and
that's where we are bringing in uh the
consultants entities whose business is
to look at these kinds of questions and
give us a strong solid technical answer
so that the proposal that goes in front
of the council uh next year is solid
and i think there is value in having
inclusion of private septic systems
uh recognizing that there'll be
certainly be limitations to that
we don't have the bandwidth to do
individual inspections of any any septic
systems uh that's
we have to make it a proactive approach
from a part of of the resident who'll
come to us and say
i want my credit come and take a look i
can show you i've been pumping i've had
it inspected
which is always a good thing to do for
any specific system now they can
leverage that and get a little break off
there better again that's preliminary
thoughts on how that might work for us
and
turn it over to gretchen for any
additional thought she might have you
know all right gretchen young um i'm the
environmental project manager for the
city of dover and um i'm also the chair
of the municipal alliance for adaptive
management which is a group of seven of
the regulated communities in the total
nitrogen general permit watershed um and
there are 12 regulated communities and a
number of those actually looked us for
some of the work that we're doing
and
so i just i mentioned that because there
are all of our communities um
have worked hard to get to a point with
epa there was a lot of negotiations to
get to a point where we have this
flexibility written into the permit it's
a five-year permit we're about half a
year almost three quarters of a year
through year one
and
there are people looking to see what
we're doing
there are
uh people just watching to make sure
that there there have been improvements
incremental improvements happening and
then five years
the epa will likely either extend the
permit allow the continued flexibility
or go to something that is more
prescriptive either more prescriptive
with respect to non-point source more or
go back to just regulating the
wastewater treatment discharge and that
is a place that as a community we do not
want to be all of our communities we
don't want to be there
so we see this
any bill really that adds flexibility
and opportunities for us to be creative
as as a positive for our communities
and so you know we really thank you for
taking a look at this thank senator
waters for
sponsoring this so that we just have
more flexibility and more opportunity to
address
nitrogen reductions in a in a cost
effective and meaningful way so we're
making real positive changes
another thing to add on
is uh there are ways to do at retrofits
to existing systems or to just put
install um there's a mecha you know
aeration device that you can put into a
septic system it's relatively low cost
about five thousand dollars maybe more
um
our subcommittee of the municipal
alliance is actually uh ours excuse me
our stakeholder committee is working on
a pilot project in installing these in
another in a number of homes
but right now as
our deputy mayor mentioned we don't have
the capacity in the city to inspect all
of these
so you know in order to really be able
to make sure that they're working we
need some way to create a self-reporting
and through using the utility um and
allowing credits it really incentivizes
not only the
uh installation of these systems but
also the self-reporting of
how they're maintaining the systems how
they're continuing to use the systems
so we really think that this is
a great opportunity for the communities
to use to build on a stormwater utility
and has a number of co-benefits such as
um you know building reserves things
like that that that have been mentioned
before so with that i'll
that's about all i have to add
any questions by members of the
committee
representative smith
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um my recollection
and i don't know if this is correct or
not is that uh initially the epa was
saying that all of the wastewater
treatment plants had to be replaced and
that got people moving in a direction of
trying to find other ways to help fix
the problem is that correct
yeah so i mean this has been going on
for a long time but
what the epa recognizes that there
is a nitrogen
impairment in the great bay and epa
their regulations
um are associated with what's called the
point source or the waste that's the
wastewater treatment plant discharge
so to get to the hypothetical levels
that uh the great bay could
could handle for nitrogen the epa was
looking for just what they call limit of
technology improvements so essentially
redoing a
system now
this has been going on for a number of
years there have been a number of
upgrades dover included has spent quite
a bit of money in 2015 to upgrade this
system so
beyond what was um
so
beyond what could potentially be
mandated which is the limit of
technology communities have made
improvements and are making improvements
but to take it to limit of technology
you start make you know you get less
return on your investment right so
people talk about there's only 30
percent
being discharged from the wastewater
treatment plants
and that's actually getting lower
because there have been in these
improvements
very very expensive to get that last
little bit so communities
said to the epa we would rather spend
our money
on the non-point source because you're
going to make more impact and
potentially less funding
does that answer your question thank you
right
it's been a while
[Music]
i've been holding this
i thought i wrote 25 minutes okay i'm
going to be very brief
i was the chair of the stormwater
commission
a number of years back and we looked at
any number of possible
alternatives for how we could begin to
get a handle on stormwater
we looked at individual properties we
looked at municipal
systems
it's very clear particularly from those
of us in the great bay estuary that
something has to be done but it's also
true relative to any of the urbanized
areas
this was what we came up with and the
commission was
had a lot of technical expertise that
had real tourists
and property owners community planners
etc and this is what they came up with
and it was
they did get into some detail about how
this might happen
i was also the chair of the
recent
shoreline septic system commission
and you have recently seen the bill
that came out of that commission
and that was also carefully weighed by a
broad number of representatives
of different interest groups um
they were there were
lakes people
there were
septic designers
there were technical people there was
des
the
report
that resulted in the bill that i brought
to you i think was last month was uni
uniformly
unanimously
supported by everybody but the realtors
i can't remember
what the boogie man was
for that bill
this is the perfect
solution the perfect marriage
of those the
results of those two commissions it get
the uh we weren't sure we thought the
utility was a really great idea it's
been a while
for
municipalities to undertake such a an
effort and i'm very proud of dover
i think manchester was playing with the
idea for a while
it it doesn't involve getting down to
the individual property owner and
and inspecting his system right
instead of looking at the black we're
looking at the white it has individual
property owners coming to the city
to to report on what their septic system
is like there's the rewards
set in instead of penalizing people who
have failing septic systems
or as the realtors object to
saying we want to look at your system
and see if it is
this provides an incentive for people to
to develop and maintain a good
septic system
so it's bringing together in total four
years of
effort of a wide
wide variety of experts and community
members
to come up with a solution that i think
is really a win-win
thank you i'd be happy to take any
questions
any questions
by members of the committee
thank you um representative spang if you
could give us an example um say i'm a pr
private property owner i've got a well
um
i'm i'm not in the great bay area but
say i'm somewhere else some other
municipal uh area so i'm i'm not on uh
seth i'm not on town sewer
how what kind of fees so would i be
subject under this if my
my town adopted this and enacted it
um
would would i be subject to possibly a
monthly fee
or would it would
i'll just leave it at that right i i
think you meant a private septic system
rather than a private well
um and i think that that's probably a
question
that would be best answered by the
deputy mayor of dover because they've
been getting into all of getting into
all the fine details about of how this
would work
and that's the beauty of it it is
enabling
and rather than coming to the
legislature and trying to get the
legislature to be comfortable with
something that applies
statewide it's going back to the
municipalities
and that's what i've come to realize is
probably where we have to go for
solutions for our environmental problems
statewide regulation is a long way into
the future getting them it's
municipalities who care about their
local water
and know their the constraints
that their landowners are under
and relying upon those landowners to
support it is where we need to go in
terms of developing that level of detail
seeing no more questions thank you very
much okay thank you with that i will
close the the hearing on uh
and open the hearing on 305.
and i thought i was again putting in
extra time when i went to
one hour each and
put up a
senator
chairman sherman we'll
hopefully this one
apologize for it uh being so long in the
previous
um thank you uh chair good to see you
again
um
for the record my name is state senator
tom sherman district 24
including
11 towns on the seacoast um
i am introducing
uh sb 305 relative to the operation of
personal watercraft and marked channels
from hampton falls to hampton harbor
this is a
straightforward
bill
in 2019
the governor signed into law
restrictions
against any use of personal watercraft
in the estuaries and the area of
hampton seabrook
harbor
and
i believe inadvertently
what it did was
selectman lane who loves who's over here
loves to use his personal watercraft but
he was restricted
from putting it in at the landing at
hampton falls
um so he came to me and asked me if i we
could revise the statute and looking
into it
there was a second bill that actually
passed the house i think on a voice vote
that would have similarly restricted use
in the back channel behind newcastle and
rye
and that was brought by representative
murray i think um
and that
that bill again would have been
a complete prohibition and that one was
vetoed by the governor
um so what this bill
aims to do and i think it does a good
job it's been amended and a little bit
um actually it is in the original form
um
the goal of the bill was to say can we
reach a compromise that ensures access
and protects the environment which was
the goal of these because these are
fragile estuary they have fragile
ecosystems
and um
but allows
people who use personal watercraft to
get out to the areas where it's really
fun
so
for
uh
mark the idea of putting in at the
hampton landing being a responsible
owner and staying in the channel not
going close to the shore going at
headway speed which is
i believe what we're supposed to do in
channels
at least that's what i do um
the idea
is
you can get out to the ocean you can get
out to the piscataqua you can get out to
beyond little harbor
and you can have fun on these watercraft
and you're not
restricted just because you have this
watercraft you know i have a whaler
which i take back in these areas and i'm
not restricted at all
um
so there's an issue of fairness and an
issue of access
and that's what this bill tries to solve
while protecting the fragile ecosystems
in
both areas
so i hope you'll
see um
see
fit to pass this and i'm happy to take
any questions and i think mark's here to
share his experience
so thank you
any uh questions by members of the
committee representative harp
thank you senator welcome um i had a
question about the 300 feet how'd you
pick the 300 feet why isn't it 150 why
isn't it 500 where'd which get the 300
i believe that's the standard
setback from
for ecosystems remember these are titles
so they're a little bit different from
our lakes
so um
300 feet gives you that buffer
um
but i'd be open i believe it's the
standard for tidal waters but i can look
into that and get back to you
she might you might know
come join me
thank you just introduce yourself
good morning for the record my name is
crystal mclean and i'm a lieutenant with
new hampshire state police marine patrol
typically when we look at the definition
of ski craft which is a very specific
type of vessel in new hampshire waters
it can go over 25 miles an hour
is less than 13 feet in length and has
the capacity to carry not more than two
people so it's basically a smaller
version of a personal watercraft and in
new hampshire law
that distance that they must be from
shore is 300 feet before they're allowed
to go over headway speed headway speed
being the slowest speed to maintain
steerage way
thank you
you can certainly stay there
any other questions
for the record she has not pulled me
over yet
pardon me
no not yet well you got a faster boat
than her
no
their votes are really fast
senator thank thank you i know more
questions but uh chris uh
lieutenant would you
uh i'll have you fill out a card because
i think but we'll probably have some
questions uh for you certainly either
shortly or
uh
because right now uh
this mr lane
is on there but you can fill out the
card because
there may be some additional additional
questions by members of the of the board
yeah thank you elaine identify yourself
yeah my name is mark lane i'm a citizen
of hampton falls and also selectmen in
the
in hampton falls as well
and i'm here in support of the bill as
senator sherman has suggested i was
i think the current law is
discriminatory and and i really have a
problem with that um and let me give you
a little story so i've been riding my
personal watercraft using that that
gateway from the depot in hampton falls
to get out into the ocean
since
i'd say probably around 2012.
and a number of people in town
and out of town have used that same
waterway some for personal watercraft
some for boats
and the boats i see out there generally
range
from you know 15 foot boats all the way
up i think the biggest one i've seen is
24 feet
so they can get quite large
um
but my quick story isn't
i think it was two years ago i
like i always do at high tide go out and
to try and get out in the ocean and i
made my way through the depot
and then i got pulled over by marine
patrol not by this officer but by
another officer and um
uh
i wasn't aware that the bill had pat or
the law had passed at the time
so she's explaining to me um
you know that the law had passed and
that i was no longer
able to use that that access way which
was unfortunate for me because it meant
in order for me to use
the the ocean i would have to deal with
the traffic in hampton try and find
parking try and pay twenty dollars or
twenty five dollars to to launch my boat
if i could actually find a place to
launch um so it became very inconvenient
um but anyway as she's explaining the
lot to me
out in the harbor
um
two boats
came
up the same passageway that i had been
that that i that i use from hampton
falls
going at relatively
much faster speed than i was traveling
quite honestly um
and so i turned her and said well why
aren't you stopping these two boats and
she said well it's not illegal for them
to use it it's illegal for you to use it
and i'm keep in mind i'm in a 13
foot personal watercraft that
that means no more than three passengers
can go on it they're in much larger
boats going at faster speeds
um
so immediately i you know that's when i
contacted senator sherman and and said
that i didn't think that it was um
that i thought the current law was
discriminatory against
um
personal watercraft now i am a
environmentalist i i believe in making
sure that we maintain and protect our
environment um
that's why i think that the bill that
senator sherman has put forward
is a sensible one
i think
changing the current law to allow
personal watercraft and boats to use
that access way
but at headway speed
is the logical um is the logical uh
uh
way to go i i guess uh
i i think it's a great compromise um
that way everyone can continue to use
the access way we can get out there we
can manage the uh environment by going
at headway speed um and uh enjoy that
particular spot and i and the only other
thing i'd add is that i think
restricting the depot in hampton falls
is a slippery slope because it's an
important area for hampton falls
citizens as well they use that depot
quite frequently
it is a great access way and as i said
earlier it's our opportunity to get to
the ocean without having to deal with uh
hampton traffic
so i appreciate the time and certainly
would be happy to answer any questions
question by anyone from the uh committee
representative spang
turn on your microphone please
thanks for coming in
it's good to
to get
the word from the from the front
um the number of
areas that are
are affected by this bill
um it seems to me extends quite a bit
farther than just the area that you're
speaking of relative to
to hampton falls
um
do you feel then that
i mean certainly what you're talking
about is included in this list
um but how do you want to comment on the
other people other places that are this
yeah
yeah i i can i can comment comment on a
few of them certainly um
the the new castle area and out behind
where the wentworth hotel is and all of
that area and i think
i think um as senator sherman said they
tried to put the current law into place
in that area and it was vetoed by um
governor sununu so i
and i also um
i i think
if i understand it correctly and
when i was when i was talking earlier um
you had mentioned that
hampton falls was the only
place in the state that had a
restriction is that accurate for
fifo
right and and but to answer your
question specifically i've had my
personal watercraft in a number of these
areas as well behind behind um
uh
specifically behind the wentworth and
kind of up through i don't know the
names of them so i can't particularly
tell which spot i'm referring to on this
list
but i think it should be the same
rules that apply because in these
current areas boats
i see boats going at fairly high speeds
i don't know if there's a law or a
headway speed law there
but
anywhere where there's
in in these areas i feel like a headway
speed law makes sense
because that way you're not doing any
damage to the environment you're not you
know you know moving water at the same
speed as you would if you're going
anything over headway speed
but
it doesn't make sense for me to allow a
boat at headway speed in any of these
areas but not allow personal watercraft
at headway speed right
follow-up
yeah having learned the hard way
i have a boat in maine and hardway is
literal
that the
configuration
particularly along coastlines and into
these estuaries changes all the time
right
so i would expect that the channel would
be changing all the time
so the 300 feet
from any marshland
is that going to be difficult for
recreationists to figure out when their
feet 300 feet
i don't think so because the channels
are well marked
so when i use the channel i'm on the
markers you know that's how i make my
way out and and i do that because i
don't want to get stuck or i don't want
to get into any trouble especially if
the tide is not high tide
and i almost never go out when it's not
three hours on either side of high tide
but i think it's
they're very well marked areas so i
think um
generally speaking i would say the
answer is no right okay and it's great
that you
have just a comment i
i was looking for the word channel in
the bill
and i it it's
in the title but i'm glad to see that it
isn't identified anywhere in the rsa
that's where that we're putting in
right and and i guess as just a
follow-up to that
if there's a law on the books that
doesn't allow
any watercraft because it's either too
shallow or the the channel's too thin
then i'm not opposed to that i don't i i
think that makes sense and i think it's
the right thing for the environment
but if it's deemed that boats are okay
to use a channel i'm not sure why
personal watercraft can't use that same
channel especially at headway speed
and i and i the only other thing i i'd
add is that
um one argument that i did here was well
it's difficult to patrol
these areas um but i can honestly say
it's not that difficult because i was
stopped so
thank you is there any other questions
by members of the committee
if not thank you very much thank you
very much
are you can you available for some
questions
and uh
i'll
maybe i'll start
with the uh picking up from
what representative spang was talking
about and then also the uh
mr elaine uh why
should it be limited to personal
watercraft not
all boats should be at headway speed
well we remain neutral on the proposed
bill uh we
understand that the
the primary reason that it's being
brought forward is due to environmental
concerns from a boating safety
enforcement perspective our patrol boats
do have the ability to patrol in the
channel areas however when we get
outside of the channels our typical
patrol boats
we require
other
vessels within the fleet to
to be able to access some of these areas
because of the tidal activity the mud
especially at low tide
i don't know
exactly why it was brought forth as
personal watercraft aside from the
environmental factors so i can't give
you a full
uh answer to your question
um
but that's my understanding
and representative smiths
yeah thank you mr chair and thank you
lieutenant for taking my question um
for could you explain um briefly
uh
why
the bill
why that particular those particular
channels in around newcastle were picked
i mean i know that we were on the boat
with you doing the field trip and it's
and it was explained to us why this was
a good way to write this and i just
wanted for the benefit of those who
don't remember or weren't there if you
could explain just how this will be able
to be patrolled kind of certainly well
in the area where the channel does exist
behind newcastle and up into the hampton
harbor areas that are specified
it does allow access to these areas and
in areas that people
recreate
they enjoy with vessels of all different
configurations
so that allows them to still access
these sites
but at the same time taking into con to
um
taking into account the
ability to monitor
and maintain the environmental quality
and aspect of it
okay thank you
anyone else from
the committee for a question
representative spain
i don't i don't know who can answer this
question possibly only the sponsor but
it's kind of stuck in my head that this
is only personal watercraft
when mr lane is alluding to
other boats
um
i don't know i guess we don't have any
of the sponsors here who could
say whether
there would be any problem with opening
up to other boats what is your feeling
about it
typically uh
at this point as we discussed earlier
this is the only area in the state where
personal watercraft specifically have
some sort of prohibition we do have
numerous lakes throughout the state
where other boats
are banned or restricted due to
horsepower restrictions engine
restrictions speed restrictions
we also have a definition for ski craft
as i testified to
earlier which is a very narrow
definition of watercraft in new
hampshire those do have additional laws
and regulations that they need to abide
by
the
the way i like to try to describe what
these types of vessels are is when we
take it to the motor vehicle world we
start with very broad categories and in
the motor vehicle world we have a motor
vehicle and in the boating world we have
a boat and then as we narrow it down and
we're getting more descriptive we go
from a boat to a personal watercraft so
we're starting to describe that a little
better
in more detail and from the boating side
a boat to a
excuse me a motor vehicle to a pickup
truck
and now we further define it
from the personal watercraft to a ski
craft and on the other side that pickup
truck to a four-door uh
you name it model version
so that ski craft is very very specific
the personal watercraft is kind of that
in-between definition and once again
currently the seacoast is the only area
that has
that specific
uh prohibition for personal watercraft
in the state whereas we do have numerous
restrictions for
the very narrow ski craft regulations
and descriptions as well as
boats in general
being prohibited on various water bodies
did mr lane have a comment
now
uh
any other questions mr hump
representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
uh taking my question i don't know if uh
you can shed light on this for me um
have you have you seen the bill i have
yet okay um i'm also looking at the
original or the one that's currently in
law
so my question is
this says
uh 300 feet from any marsh land or
flatten hampton seabrook estuary
and then on this one there's very
specific places
does the one that's in place now
cover all these specific places or are
there specific places that aren't
covered by that i believe the new
amendment would cover all of those areas
yeah uh as previously proposed okay
thank you you're welcome anyone else
questions
comments
thank you very much thank you
seeing uh
uh mr deers uh
i know you have an uh
knowledge of the area and uh
is and i'll just if you you could you
can uh
on the relative uh
the effect of
boats in the area
yeah you think it would be a good idea
if this committee put in an amendment to
uh
would you
uh to include votes as opposed to
these power crafts or you just
not my job mine
for the record my name is ted diers and
i'm the administrator of the watershed
management bureau and i will um answer
directly uh some of your question and
dance heartily around the rest okay um
that's fair
i have testified on this bill any number
of times in its former iterations
and the impetus of this bill is pretty
simple is that
some of these i think what what
colloquial
colloquially if i could get that word
out without hurting myself
um would be referred to as jet skis
um that the problem with that was that
that fomented this whole issue was
really people going out on jet skis and
tooling around in marshes
salt marshes
at low lowished uh
water so just enough water to cover the
marsh to get out through the channels
and you have these broad what be what
looks like a you know
a big field of grass during low tide at
high tide is completely covered with
water
and so people
were going out there
coming out of the channel and tooling
around and ripping up the salt marsh
because that water could be covering it
but it could only be a small bit and at
the same time also into very narrow
channels channels that are only you know
five feet wide which again
i evidently are extremely fun to be able
to move around in which stirs up
sediment which causes other issues and
erosion within those pretty delicate
channels our salt marshes are already
under pretty significant um impact
through lots of different you know
sources going on so that was the impetus
of the bill that was been the nature of
the conversation all through all of this
whether you're talking about newcastle
and the small marshes around newcastle
which again are highly impacted by by
development and other things going on
as well as all of those marshes which
are in hampton harbor which is the vast
majority of the salt marsh
in new hampshire these are incredibly
important ecosystems that's what was
recognized through the original bill and
why this became a thing
generally boats don't do that generally
boats have a propeller sure there are
jets uh jet motors for for boats but
again the issue was primarily focused on
those individual you know two
one to two person uh
craft sometimes i guess now there's
designs that have a couple more people
that you could throw on there
but that are have a very low draft and
are really built for that kind of
uh activity so the idea was to prohibit
those p those in in very specific places
that is the surface of the marshes
i think that
what we've learned and i think the
lieutenant described this very well and
i think as the speakers behind me have
spoken very well is that we learned that
that was a bit of a sledgehammer
and what's what i see in this amendment
is is taking a scalpel to it to make it
more fair for the people who are
recreating there the people who are
doing the right thing while still
protecting those marshes against the
kinds of um impacts that that the less
desirable
activities can cause
so this our our department of
environmental services has never taken a
position on this bill i've been asked to
provide the kind of testimony that i've
just provided in terms of what do we
know about salt marshes and how they
work and the impacts on them by certain
watercraft
but we've never taken a position and i
would not
dare to take a position on this bill at
this particular moment
mr dears you should be in politics
very well
that's your job sir very well very well
done all right thank you any other
questions i'm happy
i think
well you've answered i think
representative spang's question and mine
and
representative smith for the question
i just want to get a clarification so it
sounds like what you're saying is that
the jet skis as they're called
have a much shallower draft so they can
go into that shallower water but then
they just tear things up whereas a boat
like with an outboard motor or an
inboard motor
it goes deeper into the water and so
they pretty much avoid them because
they're just going to get stuck
again this is not a strict methodology
there are people behind me are much
better
much more experienced voters than i
probably around this table that are much
more experienced than i
the behavior tends to be isolated to
those kinds of craft and that's what why
it was regulated as such okay thank you
any other questions
mr lane you want to
thank you very much
thank you very much i appreciate it
mr lane
just
you have uh
yeah turn it on yep thank you again um
and i agree with everything that the
gentleman just spoke to in terms of
jet skis
going into
areas where
at low tide the marsh would be grass
i agree that should be prohibited and
what i'm suggesting is that
the the
the channel
that boats
can travel
should also be allowed to be traveled by
jet skis
the marshes can be
they
they can be patrolled
you can see
the marshland you know from the hampton
harbor so you can see if people are
going out into areas that they shouldn't
be going to but i'd also suggest that
many boats today are jet propelled that
are out there so larger boats but
so again that the whole lower draft
issue so they
technically could be going into these
areas they shouldn't be going either
so
i think the the compromise really is
in the areas that are suggested in here
where boats can currently travel
personal watercraft should also be able
to travel because they're not doing any
more damage in these areas than a boat
would do
in fact i'd argue that potentially
they're doing less because boats can go
significantly faster and create a much
larger wake
in this bill i don't think is
there everybody's allowed there it's
just their speed
it should be at headway speed i'll all
watercraft that's that's why i support
this build because i think i think
all watercraft
in these areas should be relegated to
headway speed i think that makes a lot
of sense and it's a good compromise
currently the law says boats can use
this area but
personal watercraft can't
yeah but they've got to go slow yeah
no they can't they can't
currently the
the current law says we can't go out
there at all right now
this still
this bill is saying
we should the personal watercraft should
be able to go where boats can go as long
as we're doing it at headway speed
yeah
all right thank you questions thank you
very much
anyone else
if anyone uh
no one else on the committee and now no
one else wishes to speak i will call i
will call 305 the hearing 305
closed
and i and we're right almost
a couple minutes so
this
we'll go to 258.
we're right on right back on time uh
well let's when we
get you got you got a couple of minutes
for a break
i
mean know
um
oh
excellent
uh
like
thank you
you never know do you
yep
okay
first
hello
i thank
thank you mr chairman senator david
waters district four here to introduce
senate bill
uh 258
relative degrees of african americans
alive during the period of american
enslavement
um
simple description of the bill and i'll
get into the details a little a little
bit later is that this builds on
existing statute about protection of
local
burial grounds in new hampshire to
ensure that there is participation of
the descendant
community
when we're dealing with african-american
gravesites in the in the state
there's a lot of history around these
sites uh if you're interested you can
look to a few months ago a very
extensive article in the new yorker
magazine called underground which was
looking at the rediscovery of african
american grave sites
across the country and starts out with a
quite a substantial story about the
portsmouth new hampshire
negro bearing ground but you can also
look at the new hampshire public radio
series from a
year before last uh four series that
they did of videos and stories on four
african-american burial sites in
new hampshire and then also if you go to
the um
black heritage trail of new hampshire
there is an hour long black heritage
trail history of concord that we filmed
and has quite a bit on the burial sites
in concord so if you're interested in
this in this subject and you don't have
one of these sites in your own town
there are good places to
find out about the larger history of it
and i bring this forward because uh
there has been just such a increase in a
number of african-american burial sites
across new hampshire that have been
rediscovered and that people are
interested in making efforts to preserve
restore and appropriately mark and and
commemorate them
my
my own academic work for about 40 years
i was at the university of new hampshire
i did spend a lot of my time in
graveyards and i did a lot of work on
early new england
burial grounds the restoration and
and preservation but i also come to you
as a founding board member of the black
heritage trail of new hampshire and the
portsmouth black heritage trail before
that organizations that have done a
great deal not just in portsmouth but
now across the state to identify and
preserve and mark these these sites
i think there's an extraordinary history
here and really something just
extraordinary for new hampshire to
celebrate um as we discover these things
we found these amazing people and how
they contribute to our freedom story in
the state and the values of the people
here and let me just mention uh a few of
them um perhaps the most famous is owner
judge
stains and she's famous because she was
what they called back then the body
servant of martha washington
and she escaped from the president's
house
in
philadelphia when that's before dc
washington was established as the
national capital
um because
in philadelphia
if you were an enslaved person who was
resident for more than six months
continuously you were free
and washington with his entourage of
enslaved folks first in new york and now
then in
philadelphia knew that uh this six-month
clock was ticking so he would circulate
his enslaved people
giving pretext for trips over to
delaware
which is a slave state or down to back
to mount vernon
and um owner
judge stains knew that this was in the
works she also knew that she was going
to be given as a wedding present to
martha washington's niece whom she did
not like
but she had particularly anxieties
perhaps over the fiancee of that
of that woman who was did not have a
good reputation
and you know quite likely she feared
rape um as that occurred to other of her
family members at mount vernon so she
got on a ship bound for for portsmouth
why portsmouth well george washington
had made his first presidential trip
uh to portsmouth in 1789 with his
entourage of five or six enslaved people
and you better believe they got to know
the local local community and so she
knew that she would find a welcome
welcoming reception among the black
community of new hampshire so she came
up here
and then she happened to be seen in the
streets of portsmouth by one of the
daughters of john langdon
who
knew washington's
martha washington's niece well had seen
ona
at the president's house in philadelphia
and said oh i saw ona so the word go
back to washington and he
sent slave catchers up here
repeatedly
to try to either persuade or trick or
kidnap her back into slavery so she
um took off to hide out in greenwood new
hampshire where she spent the next
almost 50 years of her
life she married a mariner
she had daughters one of whom became a
water colorist
and she lived there
what is now way out in the woods but
always threatened by capture by martha
washington or her descendants until she
died in 1848 she was interviewed two
times around 1840 and she told the story
of her thirst for freedom as she as she
as she called it an extraordinary site
it's out in the woods it's been much
damaged the stones are broken down
this is an opportunity for that site to
be recognized also mention samson battis
who had a great history related here to
concord
he was born about 1750 probably in
rollinsford or durham he was enslaved
to one of the founders john moore of
of canterbury and uh then served in the
american revolution um in
head's company we have heads portrait on
the halls down in the state house
and gained his freedom and some land a
few years afterwards and there was a
large group of african-americans
in
canterbury he had like 11 children one
of his daughters had 18 children but the
never more than five people listed in
the census who were african-american for
canterbury pretty typical
um
he was uh really famous in the early
1800s because he led the governor's
color guard in his unif revolutionary
uniform in the parade of the color guard
which would escort the governor
um for his inauguration and on artillery
uh days as well very well known in his
time um but
neglected he died at age 102 in 1852
much neglected afterwards uh his burial
ground as he was at least he's in a town
cemetery of
canterbury but he's way down in a swamp
sometimes they would bury
african-american abuse way down there
his the only stone has a marker because
he has a
revolutionary war marker but there are a
lot of other buried around him that we
don't know and then there's a badass
family burial ground
out in another part of canterbury now he
has some descendants around
but the reason for this bill is what if
we don't know who the descendants are
for example jeff he was enslaved by the
minister of deerfield and almost any
town in early
new hampshire before 1800 had a minister
there were slaves because the ministers
had enslaved people
um when the old burial ground was moved
out of the woods into the new burial
ground um they brought the minister in a
stone his body but jeff had been buried
just outside the wall also kind of
typical they left jeff
up there
recently
the
old the black heritage trail has been
placing markers for burial grounds and
noted african-american sites around the
state deerfield
hancock milford amherst just to mention
a few the most famous of course is in
concord where
it had been known that there was a negro
bearing ground in concord probably
hundreds of people
uh buried there both enslaved and and
free the black the portsmouth black
header trail placed a plaque at the head
of the street and the city decided to go
ahead and do a sewer repair
and they dug
right down into those graves and i went
i met i was there and saw the sewer pipe
running running right through the rows
of
of coffins all work stopped and if you
go to portsmouth now the descendant
community that the portsmouth decided to
name um
formed and they've created an
extraordinary monument
there and reburied those remains of
folks
uh who were nameless and unknown
otherwise but genetic work had shown
that they were of african origin there
were some filed teeth and some other
markers as as well and so now the couple
hundred people who are buried under the
houses under the street there are
respectfully
um
uh uh noted so back back to what the the
bill
does is that the logistics here is that
it again builds on
existing language in protection of bare
grounds this committee and other
committees over decades have done a
great job of making sure that our burial
grounds such a distinctive part of our
history and our landscape are protected
burial grounds in fact are owned by the
descendants of the people buried there
not by the surrounding property owner
but existing statute very carefully lays
out the property rights of the person
surrounding it so if you want to do
genealogical research or you want to go
in and do a restoration and preservation
of the site
we the legislation set up a posting
and uh and notification of land or
negotiations and to make sure that the
right kind of way
to go in there and do the work you're
going to do is be approved by the
governing body and and so on and these
are good these are good production
protections and they work very well
now sometimes it's necessary to move one
of these sites and we have good
statutory
language around that as well if it has
to happen here's the procedure and of
course dot is exempt from a lot of this
and they have their own procedures
because yes sometimes they've got to
widen a road and
sometimes the burial ground has to be
moved but in each case there's a
procedure
so what this does is that it recognizes
that we need to add on one thing to that
that if it's a grave site
where african americans
african-americans
buried from the period of enslavement
when we can be sure
that they had no control over their
burial that their family members or
others
did not have control over that process
that now if one of those graves is going
to be restored preserved
marked in some way
that the descendant community be
involved
that's kind of existing statute that if
you can find somebody who descended
you know from the bare ground you you
that they still own that so they have
rights over
what happens in there but for these
folks highly unlikely that there be any
genealogical
information about that so it names the
black heritage trail of new hampshire or
other similar organizations who would
have expertise who would kind of know
what kind of grave rituals performed at
the time what kind of internment might
have been
performed what's an appropriate ceremony
perhaps to
perform now if there's going to be a
marker put up what is the appropriate
language that might be put on that or if
there's a plaque out of the roadside or
something um what kind of plaque would
that
would that be so that's why this notion
of a descendant
community here
and then um starting on line 13
this again it is very similar to
existing language that if you're going
to
disturb or remove anything from a
african-american grave site um check in
with the descendant community
if there has to be a disturbance or
removal because of construction or
whatever whatever the reason there may
may be
then
you can do that but it has to be done
respectfully in consultation with the
descendant
community
there is one
kind of trip wire here that if it starts
to become clear that this person may
have had native heritage as well as
african-american heritage
we have the native american graves
protection and repatriation act that's
federal statute it's been around for
decades now and that has very specific
rules which new hampshire follows now
very very religiously
if such a site is identified of what you
do at that point
i will say that when i was at unh i
served as the nagpra
officer
as we dealt with human remains
of native american descent and grave
goods that there were a lot of
hundreds if not thousands of examples in
the collections at the university of new
hampshire and we had almost a 20-year
process of working with the abnaki
community to make sure that they were
returned and appropriately reburied
where there are so that that's why
that's um
uh in there and then a couple other
parts of the statute just you know
because cemetery statute is is spread
around in various
places um
that's why there's some other mentions
of other places the cemetery
trustees and so they're different places
in statute where the same language
gets put in
you also notice on page two
that online 13
new hampshire division of historical
resources
department of cultural natural resources
can serve as an advisory
capacity municipalities and descendants
they do that already now with burial
grounds and with native american
remains so that's they're there to help
if they can be of help
as well as the descendant
community
and lastly i'll mention one other aspect
of the
of the bill
this has to do with
potential human remains
and associated grave goods
that may have been removed from the
sites and maybe in other collections
for example i know that there are
grave markers for african americans
that have been removed from burial
grounds and may be on display
in one case i know are on display in a
historical
society
sometimes that's necessary you know if a
grave site's being removed or if a
marker that's left there is obviously
deteriorating and will soon be gone
then okay you know maybe that ought to
be in a museum somewhere
but there are also maybe human remains
and this is why the last paragraph here
says okay
for your medical society if you're a
university
if you're another historical society
check your collections
they're familiar with it this procedure
they've done it on the native american
things under federal statute says check
what do you have
if you have something
then you ought to
work with the senate community to see
how these appropriately and respectfully
can be dealt with
um
and who knows what's out there you know
you with the native american things we
didn't know to us and and at unh for
years said we don't have anything we
don't have anything well once we kept
asking we found out yeah we had a lot
and that was true some other places
around the state
as well so um will we find things i
suspect we will i will
just mention i know of a finger bone
necklace
that is made of at least five
individuals finger bones into a necklace
that is in a collection of one
university in the state
probably of african african-american
origin
we also know from new hampshire
histories of cases where it was very
common
that african-american graves or
or bodies would be taken or the graves
would be dug up by medical students
it's one of the reasons we first began
once the part the dartmouth medical
school was established you're going to
notice in state statute you start to see
state statute on grave robbing
because they were being used for
dissection
and there's uh one famous case where
a couple doctors from hollis
when an african-american was executed uh
they bought his body
and i did it for a dissection with their
medical students but then one of them
removed his skin had a tan and made into
a pair of boots
now i don't know if that pair of boots
is still walking around so you know some
some is somewhere in a historical
society or not but you know this
it's an unfortunate this is what
happened this is what happened these
things happen we all we all know this so
if it is the case that any of these
remains are out there let's let's take a
moment to make sure that they're
respectfully uh dealt with
um so i'm sorry to go on on so long and
i will mention mr chairman that
um
several members of the black heritage
trail
of new hampshire and other groups had
hoped to be here today i do have a
letters that were submitted um
in the uh
senate hearing and if you if they
weren't also set to you i will have them
xeroxed and you know after the hearing
i'll bring them up
up to you but uh we had a lot of people
sign in doesn't sign in support of this
in the in the senate and i have some of
those uh letters but it is sometimes
hard for people to
to uh to to get up here um so my hope is
that
you know we have a great history to
celebrate extraordinary sights and
amazing people
that are part of new hampshire history
which is just great to learn about and
so i hope that these folks whose
humanity was not even recognized when
they were alive
can have our respect
where they now now rest so thank you mr
chairman be glad to take any questions
um i when i was reading over that last
paragraph
i wasn't quite sure what it was headed
toward because it looked like
all or any of these were responsible for
inventorying
any
materials or remains anywhere in the
state
um but i i think that maybe you're
saying that they should inventory any
remains or materials in their possession
yes
yeah
okay yeah
um
exactly and maybe that's uh maybe that'd
be helpful to clarify that intention was
intended and and clearly any remains or
other materials from african-american
graves so we're not this is not a huge
fishing
expedition but
you know if you've worked with with
historical societies or museums or
universities they
they inventory things right that's what
they they inventory their collection so
i i think that they're going to be able
to go through their inventories and tell
fairly quickly if there's something they
better take a closer and closer look at
and where will these what will be the
repository of all of these inventories
and will there be a single repository
well suitable disposition um
i will say from my experience in with
both communities
with the native american community
they would want to rebury
near the site
from which they were removed
well excuse me i meant the out of all of
these inventories
when the say the university has an
inventory and i'm sorry what where will
there be a central place where
thank you for your question that doesn't
need to be
because i'm not i'm not interested in
the records as much as the bill says if
your records show you have this
then um here's the procedure
to follow and uh you know some some
communities may say well we'll we'll put
these remains um if we know where they
came from
we'll put them back there
if that site no longer exists because it
was removed maybe there'll be a
respectful place in the town cemetery
i'd just say an amherst part of the
church that was built in 1840 was built
on top of the negro bearing ground a lot
of slave inside people in amherst um so
you know and since there are
these sites there are likely to be lots
of
lots of um appropriate appropriate
places but i you know i think this is
for the communities and upon the advice
of black headers trail new hampshire and
division of historical cultural
resources to say what would make sense
here
what makes sense for this great thank
you
okay thank you very much senator
for taking the question and introducing
this bill
um i just have a question
in
on let's see page two line three
any african-american remains marker gate
or associated
mortuary or archaeological materials
that have been removed from a site shall
be returned for reburial
um
so uh i'm thinking of um it's the
archaeological materials
so i'm thinking of like
say clay pots pipes
things like personal belongings that
would normally go into a museum
or or maybe they already are in a museum
um
so now they have to go back into the
ground
thanks for your question
um that was the
the grave practices here um are
extensive uh there
there has been these archaeological
things just as you say they may be
pottery shards
they might be clamshells which are often
buried with african-american folks
there's actually um salt might be
sprinkled to still the spirit
of the of the deceased as well um there
may have been associated clothing
um in the south there's a tradition of
of memory jugs where a plastic jug would
be covered with plaster and then all the
kind of things are in the pockets or in
a household keys coins
hair brushes might be put into the
plaster and that jug was left
on the grave
breaking the pottery of the last the
last meal or the utensils that were
touched by the deceased now they were
meant to be grave goods that they were
placed there because they were
appropriate accompaniments
of the of the deceased
and um so that's that's why they are
considered grave goods and um you know
as same case with native american
materials that these are these are
considered sacred
or associated with the deceased and
ought to go back
in the ground uh so that spirit can
continue
um to rest so that that's what museums
are doing now i mean again this is this
kind of repatriation or returning or
reburial is something that a lot of
these collections are quite
uh quite used to because of their other
experiences so that that's that's why
um this is recommended here and i and i
would just say you know to be personal
about it that i buried my father with
his cane
and uh had a distinctive silver top
and goodness knows if that gravesite had
to be dug up for a highway or something
i i wouldn't want that cane that was
that was with him i wouldn't want that
going to the museum somewhere you know
that's why i put it in a coffin with
them
so i think we can kind of have a sense
and african-american specialists in this
can tell you very very
extensively about how these rituals
performed and what they meant to people
i know
it's
it is stuff um
it the the act is relative to
african americans alive during the
period of american enslavement but i see
in the parts of this bill
that's that
seems to be part of the discussion
especially toward the
the uh
part on
page two but it has been probably
possibly also in others
about um
the
it's just simply speaks to
african-american graves period doesn't
uh
doesn't differentiate in the time period
and is that intentional or
yes thanks for your your question but i
i reference back to line 10 on page one
right 10 to 11.
so this
this is why i had a definition section
in the bill okay so african-american
grave
as it's used for the rest of it
means
the grave of an individual of african
descent
who was or was likely to have been alive
during a period of american enslavement
okay
so that that definitional
carries with it and and the reason for
that is that you know i mean somebody
who died a few days ago
but that period of enslavement is when
they likely
know control the family or nobody the
the enslavers are no control over where
they're buried or how they were buried
that's that's why and also would have
would have this historical significance
issue okay
all right that's uh answered my question
uh
any other questions by uh
representative
thank you for taking my question i don't
understand
uh the descendant aspect of it i mean
how do they find descendants is that a
very involved process i don't understand
that part of it
thanks for your question and you know
it's the case on all of our burial
grounds
um
you know some of them have very
prominent markers with lots of names and
by the way they're oftentimes people are
still in town right
um so sometimes that is that is quite
easily known
other times it may be that the family
has left you know moved moved to ohio
where the farms aren't tilt-wise back in
the 1800s
or otherwise are not are not known so
the existing statute says
existing statute
on this and we'll cover this is that
um here's the procedure you use to try
to identify
and you do a posting
and if you're on genealogical research
you can't discover when do post it
and if there's nothing come up with the
posting
then you work with the town that's the
kind of existing language
what this is just saying same thing
that if you don't know
if there are any descendants around
uh that have already been identified for
the african-american
person
same procedure you approach you try to
find out but then if you cannot
determine
that's when the descendant community
kicks in
to say that those those individuals i
mean this is what was done in portsmouth
um
anonymous graves 200 people
who knows and any descendants valerie
cunningham's research
could not find descendants of anybody
she discovered from that early
early period in portsmouth so that's why
the um
the
cities
formed and assembled a special
commission
that had
the african-american um
organizations
named as the descendant community who
then worked with
how to do the re-burial and and so forth
there's you know surprising though i
published in our extensive article about
samson badass amazing
man what a patriot
about almost 20 years ago now
and i started to hear almost instantly
from descendants of samson battis
all over the country and uh
and they said wow we didn't know this
story and then there's some in new
hampshire too and now they are very
active about
um i have a family organization and
about about these sites so you never
know you know
um that people might
might might might appear um but that's
i'm sorry for such long answers on this
stuff you can tell
do this for a second time
thank you i'm thinking about our friend
in newmarket i guess there's uh
some
event to uh to recognize him is it this
saturday
i will turn it over to the
representative the honorable
representative from new market
wentworth chazwell another extraordinary
patriot okay
thank you we'll see you there
my question is
in his case he was
half white and half
negro
he um
i i assume that he was
a post
slavery
era but how about the other mulattos
who
were
living in new hampshire at the time that
of slavery
possibly were not slaves themselves or
their descendants were slaves themselves
you mentioned what happens to those that
were partially indian native american
[Music]
can i put any finer point on it to make
well i mean i i understand your question
representative and thank you and um
i'll say we went with chess will he was
um free he was born
free
as was and um
so there were free people of color
in new hampshire from a from relatively
early time for various
for various reasons
um
now
the reason says period of american
enslavement is that you might be a free
person of color at that time
but you were not you may not be what we
consider truly free
there are great restrictions on what
property you could own what kind of
education you get uh
well it's funny enough you could vote
for a little bit then you couldn't vote
you go to public school for a while but
then you couldn't
so the period of an american enslavement
there is a kind of an assumption in the
bill that the folks from that time
may not have had a free choices over
their lives in certain ways and their
grave sites might be
neglected
or
unmarked
um
now you this notion of you know well
you're kind of asking who's black and is
not right and um that that's such a
problematic aspect of our
history as americans right you know
and so i think that we have
kind of as we allow and census people
self-identify and i think we need to be
very respectful about whether we're
trying to legislate about how
black or how white or how indian or how
not indian you know what i'm saying so
i'm
i'm i'm just soon i'd be i haven't been
silent
just now because i've talked but i'd i'd
much rather be silent on those kinds of
two finances personal issues
thank you
any any other questions by members of
the committee i have one
uh money
there's enough there is an fn on this
but it doesn't uh
is there
is there a cost
to what we're to to what's
proposed well thanks for your question
um the fn was here i i crafted it
carefully to say that there was no no
new duty really or any i mean the um
cultural resources ben wilson others
they they supported the bill said we
could if we're asked to help this what
we do already will help so there's no
finance cost to them the potential here
is that anytime we pass a statute if
somebody violates it that's what the
physical note says well let's say
somebody violated this they went with a
backhoe and dug up a
you know an african-american burial
ground and um they would have violated
the statute so
or let's say already 2026 that
this some collection has that fingerbone
necklace and they haven't dealt with it
yet that's
potentially violation so that's the
physical note said well but you know
like we often get well potentially a
violation how many cases will there be
will we have to prosecute or not who
knows as far as the cost of taking care
of these sites um there's a lot of
volunteer activity a lot of eagle scouts
um a lot of you know in the markers that
have been placed um in hancock and
elsewhere recently
um there is a fund and the black
heritage trail new hampshire has a fund
to place markers they cost about 1500
each we're paying for that
there are
local events
new markets you're going to be hearing
about that
the effort to
put a
new grave marker went with cheswell's
site to we have there's a state highway
marker there and there's a fund for that
already
um so anyways i don't i don't see any
expense in the bill mr chairman okay
you should say yeah enforcement was also
going to be part of that question but
you jumped to it already
any other questions by members of the
committee
um thank you very much um just to to
carry on what uh representative renzula
said so what if somebody disturbs a uh
uh african-american
site now like you were talking about
with a digging up
the streets in portsmouth
what is
there are they're violating they're
already in violation right if they don't
take care of the
they're not yeah
thanks for your question dude process
thank you yeah i mean this is this makes
no change to existing statute if your
backhoe hits something
you know and look a lot of these bare
grounds you get out in the woods and uh
the reason they're discovered there's no
wall there's no markers that somebody's
out there taking trees down or digging a
foundation whoops bones
so we we already have
procedures for all of that the work
stops the archaeologists the state
historical resources comes comes in and
they figure out what they got to do
no change
thank you so much and i have to dash but
for any other questions and would you
like me to make xeroxes of the letters
that came into the senate
we'll do
mr chair i was premature in um signing
that pink card i'm a co-sponsor so i
shouldn't speak correct
i may
oh okay
i see
well one of these days i will learn
well
thank you mr chair i'm really happy to
be here and thank you honorable members
of this committee i think that um
senator waters covered just about
everything but i just want to say that i
um support this bill i understand the
importance of um
preserving burial grounds um i'm sort of
like a history um
amateur history buff um focusing on the
civil war and
uh civil war um
veterans my
fourth great grandfather
was a civil war veteran and
he served at petersburg strawberry farm
and a few other places and so that's
what got me interested in um history
but i find it really rewarding
uh and
one of the things that strikes me is
that i did not know about
my fourth great grandfather until about
15 or 20 years ago when a relative sent
me a copy of his uh obituary i was able
to go on to ancestry and find his burial
site
um
a picture of it actually and it was like
just an incredible experience for me i
got
chills went through my entire body you
know just seeing his his gravesite so i
just want to say that i'm in support of
the bill and thank you for listening to
me
welcome thank you very much any
questions members of the committee
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question representative um
senator waters indicated you may tell us
a little bit about mr chaswell
sure
okay for those who don't know um
wentworth stressful was a resident of
new market he was a revolutionary war
veteran
and he was one of the town fathers in
new market and it's said that he is
was the first
african-american the first person of
african-american descent that uh was an
elective official
right now in new market we're having a
sort of like um what requests will
renaissance and
the townspeople it's a private group of
about 150 to 300 members
of the wentworth successful appreciation
society that is raising money to
actually have a monument
uh built
for mr cheswell
and then this weekend uh saturday
april 9th
there is a celebration at the newmarket
mill buildings
about um
wentworth casper to celebrate his
birthday um
because we had scheduled one for last
year but it was cancelled because of the
can't pandemic but if anyone would like
more information about that you can
certainly shoot me shoot me an email
so well thank you
for listening to me and it's really
great to be here
you're welcome
i keep forgetting to turn this thing on
and off
thank you very much
uh what's the blue sheets
uh yes uh
do you have
you have the blue sheets over there
maybe yes
uh yeah might as well
well
he'll be back
he'll go he'd fake gee i'm light
there you go thank you no problem
all right uh
what do we
have 305 which we just heard
mike edgar
signed in pro
that was
three wait a minute real that was 305
and there was no one signed in on the
one we just heard
and
the reese the 257
uh
both pro was again
is it mike edgar and
uh that's grays from the new municipal
association both
both both in uh both in favor yes
uh
i had hope to be able to sit and
chat about a few things about these
bills but i
don't know but that's why i built in the
the extra
the extra time
so much for that good idea
and so it pretty much got used up the
but
just
what i see
there we'll
we will probably they'll be
we will take we are going to be taking
care of all of the bills uh on the 20th
on the 20th uh there is a we're having
three things go on at night and we'll
have at nine o'clock
on the 20th that's a wednesday
we will have
a presentation by the uh
by the weeds committee
exotic aquatic weeds and animal species
committee right like i said the weeds
committing
and
then
that should go to probably ten o'clock a
little bit later than that we
then we will have a
caucuses committee caucuses that
from 10
from 10 o'clock to
quarter of
10 45
republicans will be here as normal and
you'll find something for
and then uh
they'll
after that we will execute these
exact them all oh wait uh
that's yeah we do have a new bill
so
we're gonna have to do that as well
uh
so
i'll get together with
with which suzanne and bob
work out where we stick it in where we
where we
stick that bill in whether we do it
before
or after
the exact session
we'll see how we we'll see how it works
out
but other than that
that's that's where we're going from
here
just keep going
just is there a possibility at our next
meeting of the bill you just spoke of
yeah that we have a public hearing and
executive in the same days there's just
a possibility we'll have to the last
bill yes
absolutely okay so people should know
there isn't you know it could be another
exec there that's great thank you no no
not not for one bill
uh
perfect thank you yeah that one
especially when it comes when it came in
from
off the transom because
we were i was told it was that uh no you
don't got it anymore okay so
just just so i
i
i put in the notice for the grip for the
hearing and
right after the notice went in and
showed the bill the bill showed up
anything else uh questions if not
evan
have a nice rest of the week
yeah
it's all
hearing is adjourned
you